virtually or
physically uh so i'm very excited that
uh
dylan also agreed to give a tutorial so
dylan has done fantastic recent work at
the on the theoretical foundations of
reinforcement learning and so today he's
going to give the morning session
tutorials on uh
theoretical foundations of reinforcement
learning
and this is going to be sort of like a
preparatory tutorial for the afternoon
tutorial where we're gonna also go uh
into multi-agent reinforcement learning
which is one of the themes of the
semester so uh thank you very much dylan
and
looking for it
yeah and if you have a oh okay okay
i didn't quite hear that last part but
um should i uh begin
yes all right great
yeah um so yeah thanks for having me um
yeah as you said i'm gonna be talking
about sort of
recent progress on the theoretical
foundations of rl and uh you know this
is a workshop about learning in games
this is going to be focused almost
entirely learning on on learning and not
so much on games but yeah the point is
to sort of give the necessary background
for cheese tutorial later in the
afternoon which we'll build on this
um and yeah let me just say uh we should
have time feel free to interrupt if you
have uh questions
so let's get
started um so this talk
we're focusing on the theoretical
foundations of rl but i'm going to be
doing this from something like
a machine learning or like a statistical
learning perspective
and if you're new to rl the way i'd
summarize the difference between these
is to say you know machine learning is
about predicting patterns whereas
reinforcement learning is about using
data to make decisions
and so when i say predicting patterns
i'm talking about these domains where
we've seen you know huge breakthroughs
in the last decade like you know
computer vision machine translation
where machine learning is allowing us to
process massive amounts of data and
extract patterns like you know what
features of this image correspond to a
cat or a dog but when i say making
decisions i'm talking about tasks like
picking what treatment we should give to
a patient based on their medical stats
or you know what signals we should send
to our robots actuators based on what
we're currently uh seeing on our camera
and so the excitement about rl you know
this is really about the fact that it
gives us a paradigm that we can use to
move beyond uh just predicting patterns
to building ai systems that can act on
these uh predictions or act on data to
make decisions
and so the first thing i'm going to do
because it'll be something like a
running theme in this tutorial is
to go into a bit more depth in
illustrating the differences between ml
and
decision making so like rl
but also some parallels
so i'm actually going to walk through
three different problems the first will
be the classical supervised learning
problem
and then we'll look at the contextual
bandit problem and
the reinforcement learning problem and
so i like to think of these as sort of
uh points on a spectrum of problems
where we're adding additional
interactivity and feedback on top of
basic supervised learning and uh yeah
contextual bandits and rl
these are what i would call interactive
decision making problems
so let's start with supervised learning
um so i'm going to try to describe how
we use supervised learning to
solve new problems when we encounter
them in the wild
and we'll look at this in three steps so
the first step will be that we will pick
a class of uh what we'll call like
models or hypotheses that are trying to
capture our prior knowledge about the
world or about the problem we're trying
to solve so for vision we might think
convolutional neural nets capture our
prior knowledge well
for text classification we might think
you know linear models maybe work well
but we're going to take this as a given
then in the next step
we're going to gather a data set
consisting of examples so like x is a
feature vector here y is a label
and then the last step we're just going
to find a model that fits this data set
well
and you know we'll return this and
usually the hope will be that it will
generalize well
to future examples
so supervised learning is a really
passive problem
um the contextual bandit which i said is
kind of like the next step up this is an
online or sequential problem where now
we have to actively make decisions on
the fly in an unknown environment and so
the setup is at each time
if we're the learner we'll receive
what's called like a context or you can
think of as like a feature vector
xt we'll select an action or a treatment
80
and then we'll receive a reward rt
for the action we take and our goal will
be to pick these actions so that we
maximize the total reward
but to make this a little more concrete
if we think about something like
personalized medicine
here we can think of this as each time
we have a patient arriving we look at
their their medical stats which could be
like this context
our action will be the treatment we
propose
and the patient's response will be our
reward so we can sort of use this model
to find personalized treatment policies
based on responses
um
but you might be wondering at this point
well okay what does this have to do with
supervised learning um what ties these
problems together is the fact that we
would like to work with models so
when we design algorithms we want to be
able to use function approximation to
capture things like rewards or treatment
effects like if i have a particular
patient and i take a particular action
what's their response
um but the environment uh is going to be
unknown to us so we don't know what
model is going to work well in advance
in advance so we need to learn this from
data as we're making our decisions
okay
and
a really important detail which i didn't
mention so far is in the contextual
bandit we're not allowing our actions to
influence how this context is evolving
but if we do allow our actions to
influence the context we call it a state
instead and this brings us to precisely
the reinforcement learning problem
so this can be a better model for
domains like say robotics where the
actions we're taking have long-term
impacts on like how our system evolves
um but this is a harder problem because
it requires
uh kind of like long-term planning so we
need to be able to explore our system
and figure out you know how do we get
from point a to point b
um and again just like in supervised
learning and contextual bandits we want
to be able to learn models from data
here as well but now we're typically
going to want a model to capture things
like long-term rewards or what are the
dynamics of the environment that our
agent lives in
so
altogether
we kind of have this hierarchy of
problems what i claim is and this is
going to motivate a lot of the results
we'll go over in the tutorial uh there
are some big gaps between our
capabilities for supervised learning and
for
reinforcement learning and more broadly
decision making
and i'll just briefly give a taste for
why this is
so machine learning as we've already
discussed this is great at prediction
problems like if i want to predict do
images contain cats or dogs i have lots
of data where i know the right answer
for every example
machine learning is great at processing
this data to make predictions
but where we run into issues is
in in rl in decision making we want to
act on these predictions to make
decisions like what treatment to give
and this introduces feedback loops and
these are what really bring a lot of the
challenges to the picture so for
starters
once we have feedback loops
you know the decisions we make can
influence kind of what data we actually
get to collect
um and this introduces like the need for
counter factual reasoning the point
being if we think about say like
medicine
we only get to see the outcome for the
particular treatment we prescribe and
what we really care about is what would
have happened if we had selected our
treatment differently
um
but going even further though
again if we think back to these domains
like robotics the decisions we make are
influencing the state of the world that
generates our data and we really have to
be strategic to control how this state
evolves
um and so all together
the consequence of these feedback loops
is
if we try to naively apply machine
learning techniques to to rl and
decision making without accounting for
things like counter factuals or
long-term impact
we end up with models that have higher
error
and we make
you know bad decisions so
the point of this tutorial is to kind of
give an overview of
the algorithmic principles that we can
use to get a handle on these feedback
loops and hopefully make good decisions
so this is going to have a couple of
parts
the first thing we're going to do is
just go through basic concepts and
solutions like how do we set up the rl
problem formally what are basic
challenges that you know any algorithm
needs to address like exploration and
generalization
um and building on these issues
the the focus sort of later in the
tutorial will be to try to get up to
speed on our current understanding of
the statistical
landscape of reinforcement learning like
what assumptions do we need to make on
the environment we're trying to learn to
control what algorithm design principles
do we need at if we want to like attain
sample efficient algorithms for rl and
this is going to be
mostly focused on sort of the
statistical aspects of rl and less
focused on computation though we will
touch on some of these issues
and of course the real goal here is to
get you prepared for cheese tutorial
which is going to build on these ideas
in the multi-agent setting
so that's that's kind of the game plan
um
and so let's dive in so
i'll start by getting through just the
the introductory concepts but i'll give
kind of a more refined outline for the
talk once we have these out of the way
so
i want to start by
formalizing the reinforcement learning
problem um in this tutorial we're going
to walk work in what i'll call like an
episodic
reinforcement learning setting
and when i say episodic you should think
of a setting where i get to run my robot
for a bit
and then stop and reset it back to its
starting position
so the way we'll set this up is
our agent will live in what's called a
markov decision process
and this is going to evolve as follows
so
we're going to have an initial state
which is called x1 and this will be
drawn from an initial state distribution
d1
and then we're going to run for big h
steps so big h in this talk is what
we'll call the horizon this is like the
length of an episode
and
in each step in a given episode
uh we're first going to look at the
current state which will be denoted x h
so script x here is what we'll call the
state space
we're going to select an action to take
based on the current state
which we'll denote by a sub h so script
a is going to be our action space
then
two things will happen so first we'll
receive a reward
based on the the state we're in and the
action we took
and then we will see
uh a transition to the next state so
we'll our system will evolve and again
this will be based on the current state
and what action we took
so that's one state step
and we're going to keep doing this until
we reach the end of the episode and the
task we're interested in here is
how do we maximize
our total reward across the whole
episode
that is
we want to find a policy which is just a
mapping from states to actions
that maximizes uh this expected total
reward function which we'll call j pi so
um just a note on notation e superscript
pi in this talk will denote like
expectation under this process where our
mdp evolves with actions selected
according to the policy pie
um
so that's that's the basic goal is
maximizing our rewards
but i haven't said anything about like
learning yet how do we set this up as
a learning problem
um well what we're going to do is we're
going to assume that initially this mdp
is unknown to us so the only way we
actually get information is by
running policies or selecting actions
and seeing the resulting sequence of you
know states and rewards and so which
we'll call a trajectory in this talk by
the way the trajectory is like all the
data we see when we uh do an episode of
our
uh markov decision process
um
in particular though
uh
the way we'll set this up is we get to
run for capital t episodes so t capital
t is the number of episodes and now i'm
using superscript little t to denote
what episode we're in
and so we want to learn a good policy by
running for mini episodes and there's
there's a couple ways you can formalize
what it means to do this so
um the first model which is often called
pack rl like pac means probably
approximately correct just like in
statistical learning
um and this is we're gonna run for a
bunch of episodes then we're gonna
output a policy and we want this policy
to be epsilon close to optimal
um and ideally we'd like to do this
using as few episodes as possible
um another
notion we can look at is what's called
regret
and this is where we're going to look at
cumulative sub-optimality across all of
these episodes so like not just how good
the final policy is but how good are we
doing along the way um and i'm using pi
star here to denote the the optimal
policy which i don't know
um
and so the goal in this regret setup is
usually we want our regret to be
sublinear in t
like say root t which means that if we
look at our average performance this is
converging to optimal asymptotically
and i'll just say
uh you know regret and pack
these can actually be reduced between
one another and you only lose a little
bit in terms of either dependence on
epsilon or dependence on t in doing this
so
for this tutorial we're gonna
work with whichever one is sort of
convenient for presenting certain
results
um
let me uh double check on the questions
there's a question
oh yeah
what's the second question uh to be
clear the state space is not a dag um
yeah we're not going to assume it's a
dag in this tutorial but
there's really not a lot of loss of
generality by doing this unless you care
about
you know precise dependence on like this
parameter h in the in the sorts of
learning guarantees you're looking for
okay um let me just say a couple more
notes about this model
um
so there's many variations you can
consider we were sort of looking at many
small episodes you can or you can
imagine instead looking at like one
giant very long episode like a single
trajectory
you can also look at settings where you
know maybe you have an infinite horizon
and the game just stops once you reach
some goal state
um another thing to be aware of is you
know we're waiting rewards uniformly
it's also very common to discount future
rewards based on how far off they are
which is useful when you look at
infinite horizon problems um and these
are all good concepts to be familiar
with if you want to go through and like
digest the literature and compare
results
but we're focusing on the episodic
setting because it's sort of the
simplest conceptually but it really
captures the essential uh statistical
considerations
okay
and on that note
uh
as i mentioned
our goal is to sort of learn in a sample
efficient manner and so this means
finding a near optimal policy
with as few episodes as possible and i'm
going to try to give a sense here for
what it means to be sample efficient
so we're going to look at a pretty
simple example which is going to be
an mdp
where the state space is structured as a
tree with exponentially many leaves so
let's say we have only two actions to
start
um we're going to start off at the root
of the tree like that's the initial
state and each action we take we'll
choose whether we go left or right in
the tree
but the trick is
we're going to make it so that only a
single leaf in this tree has a reward
all the others have zero reward
and what you'll see is
there's essentially no way for us to do
better than explicitly trying
every path through the tree until we get
a reward
or in other words the sample complexity
for this problem like the number of
episodes we need to do to learn a good
policy this is going to be exponential
in the horizon
so
exponential sample complexity
this is not great if we're trying to
attack uh like say real world problems
and so the conceptual takeaway here is
we need to make additional modeling
assumptions
if we want to be able to
you know design interesting algorithms
and get interesting guarantees and so
you should really think of rl as not
just one problem
but a family of problems depending on
you know exactly what assumptions we
make
and we'll see many examples of modeling
assumptions later on but before looking
at that i want to cover some features
that will be common across all these
different settings
um yes because this is linear in the
cardinality of the state space and i'll
say more about the cardinality of the
state space as we go on as well because
in some sense this is also something we
would like to avoid
cool
so the viewpoint we're going to adopt in
this tutorial which i believe this
originally came from john lankford is
we're going to break sample efficient
learning into
sort of three key challenges um and
we're going to call these credit
assignment exploration
and
generalization
i'm going to go over each of these
challenges individually and the point
will be somehow that any full solution
to the reinforcement learning problem
needs to put all of these together
okay um
let's first look at credit assignment
so credit assignment is asking let's say
i take a series of actions
where i'm trying to get through a maze
but i hit a dead end or i run out of
time and i don't reach my goal so how do
i figure out which of these actions was
wrong or in other words how do i assign
credit for the final outcome to each
individual action to figure out which
ones were good and bad
um
there's a classical solution to this
problem which is what's called dynamic
programming and this is approach that
allows us to solve what's called the
planning problem which means
let's say we know the rewards and
transition probabilities and we just
want to calculate the optimal policy so
there's no uncertainty here
and the basic idea is
let's say we're trying to solve a maze
we'll start at the goal state and for
each of the states that neighbor the
goal we'll check what's the optimal
action to get us toward the goal
and then we'll for the neighbors of
these states we're going to repeat the
same process and we're going to keep
doing this recursively
and okay so to explain this formally
we're going to introduce what are called
value functions or uh like reward to go
functions
and these
this is a concept we're going to use
throughout the talk so
uh the optimal state value function
which we'll call v star here
this is asking
what is the reward i get if i start in
state x at time h
and then follow the optimal policy pi
star until the end of the episode
uh so it's like the reward to go at say
x if i follow pi star
um and then you can similarly define uh
what's called the state action value
function which we're calling q star
these are also sometimes called q
functions
and this is this is very similar it's
just asking
suppose i started in state x then take
action a and then follow pi star until
the end of the episode what's the reward
that i get
um and i'll just briefly mention because
this will come up later you can imagine
defining analogous value functions for
policies besides pi star and we'll
denote these by q pi and d pi
so
let's look at dynamic programming
dynamic programming is going to give us
a way to compute these value functions
and the point will be that once we have
these we can easily back out the optimal
policy
so we'll start off by setting v star h
one to zero this is saying like once the
episode's over there's no more reward to
go
and then we're going to apply what's
called the bellman equation and this or
like bowen's optimality principle this
is just saying
for each little h
let's imagine that i've already computed
v star for little h plus one
so if i know this
then q star h of x a this is just the
expected value of my reward for the
current step
plus the expected value of v star h plus
1 under the next state evolution
so that gives me q star
uh once i have q star
v star is just the the max of q star
and the optimal policy is just the arg
max for q star
um and one quick note here is like
because we have a finite horizon
the optimal policies in this setting are
going to uh depend on the horizon in
general so that's why i have this h
subscript here
okay
so this is great
um
but we'll note that this requires two
things um this requires that i know the
system's dynamics or the transition
probabilities so that i can compute this
expectation
and naively this also is going to
require that i like enumerate over all
the states so i can compute you know q
star of x a for all x a pairs um so both
of these are kind of problematic if
we're only accessing our system through
running policies and seeing the outcomes
and so you shouldn't think of this as a
solution to learning with an unknown
system just think of it as a way to plan
or optimize if you already know the
system
but we will build on this
all right that's credit assignment um
let's move on next to
the the next challenge which is
exploration
um exploration is asking okay
given that i'm in this unknown
environment
how should i select my actions so that i
can gather data that will help me to
learn
more about this environment
um so the simplest setting we can look
at which exemplifies this issue is
what's called the multi-orange bandit
problem and this is a special case of
reinforcement learning where we have
horizon one and we also just have a
single state
so for example
you can think about a setting where
i have some patient
and my action is a treatment that i'm
trying to recommend to the patient to
help them feel better and here i'm just
visualizing the reward distribution
for each treatment
and so the basic issue we see here is
you know
we only see the response for the
particular treatment we propose
like if we give ibuprofen we don't see
how you know we see how the patient
responds to this but we don't see how
they would have responded to other
treatments um and this means we have
sort of a trade-off between
gathering data
and exploiting what we already know so
exploiting on one hand means you know
greedily taking actions we think are
good given the data we've gathered so
far exploring means selecting actions
we've seen less of so that we can well
maybe like better estimate their rewards
in the future
so let's look at a classical approach to
dealing with this problem
this is going to be called the like
upper confidence boundary ucb algorithm
and the idea here is
let's say i'm at a given like let's
let's say i've already interacted for
some number of rounds i've collected a
bunch of rewards
given all of these rewards i've
collected
i'm going to estimate the mean reward
for each action and build confidence
intervals around this
and then i'm just going to pull the
action or play the action that has the
highest upper confidence bound
this kind of balances
exploration and exploitation implicitly
because we either
get a large reward or shrink a large
confidence interval
and what you can show is that
uh the number of rounds this approach
needs or i should say episodes but you
know an episode here only has length one
the number of episodes this approach
needs to find an epsilon sub-optimal
policy is number of actions over epsilon
squared and the regret scales as root a
t
so in both cases we're kind of linear in
the number of actions
and the dependence on epsilon and t that
you see you can think of as coming from
like statistical deviations um and i'm
actually going to spend a minute
sketching how we prove this algorithm
works because we're going to build on
this to look at solutions for more
complex problems
so
i'll start by formally describing this
algorithm
uh so if we're at episode or round t
we're going to let n t of a
denote the number of times we've played
action a
and we'll let f hat t
denote the like sample means from the
data we've collected so far
and then for each arm we'll define what
i'll call an upper confidence bound
f bar t
and this is going to be the sample mean
plus a bonus function that depends on
the arm and this bonus is going to be
set proportional to root one over the
number of pulls for that particular arm
or action
um and once we have this
we're just going to pull the action that
maximizes f bar t
okay
so the idea here is f bar t i'm going to
prove this now this is kind of like an
upper confidence bound so this is going
to always upper bound f star
um and so this is why we call this ucb
right
um but i'll break this into a couple of
steps
and the first step of the proof will be
to show that f bar t is indeed an upper
confidence bound um and this is a
property that we sometimes call optimism
like
um
f bar t is optimistic about what the
outcome will be because it always thinks
it will be better than the true outcome
so
um we're going to look at the zuma
huffting inequality which is this you
know basic concentration bound and this
is an inequality that says if i
look at if i have a sequence of random
variables z1 through zn
and i look at the average distance
between
you know their sum of these variables
and some of their conditional
expectations
the scales is one over root n with high
probability
so to come back to the bandit problem
uh we're gonna let uh f star of a denote
the mean reward function for action a
and what huffting will tell us is that
time t
if we look at the error between f hat t
and f star this scales as root one over
n t of a and um i'll just mention here
i'm being gonna be imprecise about like
log factors and this sort of thing in
this stuff okay
so the idea here is
that the distance between these
functions is proportional to root one
over nt of a and so because we set this
bonus here also proportional to root one
over n t
uh the bonus is going to cancel out this
error and so we'll will be guaranteed
that f bar t is optimistic it upper
bounds f star
okay
and so why is this good well the point
of optimism is that we'll be able to
prove that our sub-optimality is
dominated by like the bonus for the
action that we play
so
uh if we look at
the max value of f star like the optimal
reward minus f star of a t
uh we're going to be able to upper bound
this by the max value of f bar t using
the optimism property
and because a t was chosen to maximize
the upper confidence bound this is the
same as f bar t of a t minus f star of a
t
and so at this point we're in really
good shape because this is just the
error between fro of our estimate on a
particular action and so we'll actually
be able to both mount this like up to a
factor of two again by this bonus itself
it's root one over n t of a
and so finally we can sum this error
across all of our rounds or across all
of our episodes
and
using kind of like a pigeonhole type
argument which uh
i'll leave for you to work out yourself
you'll be able to show that this sum of
root one over nts scales as root number
of actions times t which gives the
regret bound we wanted
i mean that's it
really the key here is because we're
optimistic our error is controlled by
the range of these bonuses but only for
the actions we play and that's good
because it means
if we play an action and it has bad
reward the bonus has to be big but every
time this happens like the counter for
that action increments and this can only
happen so many times without the bonus
you know shrinking by a lot
okay and i'll just briefly mention
there's another simpler method which is
good to be aware of called epsilon
greedy and this this is just an
algorithm that says estimate the rewards
most of the time you just play the
action that our estimated reward
function thinks is good and otherwise
you explore uniformly at random so this
actually is the same sample complexity
but it has slightly worse regret but
like the real issue which we'll see
later is it doesn't generalize very well
to more complicated problems
okay
uh let's move on to the last of these
core challenges which is
uh
generalization
so generalization is asking
so now that i've gathered a bunch of
data consisting of like observations and
outcomes
how can i learn concepts from this data
that will allow me to act on
observations that i've never seen before
like so one way we can address this
issue is to revisit this supervised
learning setting from the intro
this time from a slightly more technical
perspective
so in supervised learning i have this
data set consisting of past examples
and i'm going to fit you know a model
using this like what i'm calling a model
class or hypothesis class script f
this is going to give me a hypothesis
that i can use to make predictions on
future examples
and the natural question to ask here is
when is this approach going to be
successful at generalizing to future
examples
and so what the theory of statistical
learning provides is complexity measures
that allow us to quantify how successful
we are at generalizing and i'm just
going to give a representative result
here
and this will be for what's called
empirical risk minimization which is one
of the most ubiquitous supervised
learning algorithms
so this is just the algorithm that
finds the hypothesis with the lowest
error on our training data
and then returns this and that's it
and so what statistical learning tells
us is if our data is iid
then empirical risk minimization
even though it only looks at training
data
its prediction error on future examples
is just as good as if we knew the true
distribution
up to some error term which is going to
zero as we get more samples oh so n is
the number of samples here
um and the the interesting thing to
focus on in this bound is what i'm
calling comp of script f here and this
will be a notion of like statistical
capacity or complexity that reflects how
rich our function class is and i'll give
a taste for what this looks like
so
perhaps the most well-known
notion of capacity and statistical
learning
is what's called vc dimension
which you may have seen before i
there there are many others you know
that that are you can look at like
there's you know it's called rata marker
complexity or covering number
all of these give notions of how
flexible a function class is and these
are all sort of necessary and sufficient
for learning in different worst case
senses um and i'm not going to use any
of these concepts in detail in this talk
i'll be very sketchy about this so i'll
just give a couple examples that we can
revisit so
if you have a finite class of functions
you can take this capacity to scale with
log number of functions
and if you have a
linear
hypothesis class
then there are complexity measures that
you know scale either with like the
dimension like the number of features
um or on the magnitude of the weights
depending on the model
but the key point is that all of these
complexity measures
uh they don't explicitly depend on the
size of the observation space or like
the feature space or for rl like the
state space um these only care about how
expressive your function class is once
you project it onto
whatever the sort of feature space is
and this is reflecting the fact that
you're
generalizing and so one idea i want to
come back to before moving on is well
why do we care about using flexible
model classes and generalizing
and the point is
if we look at like typical rl
applications
here we usually have states
that are going to be like rich and high
dimensional like in robotics the states
i have could be raw pixels from a camera
um and so the point is we want to be
able to use flexible models or
hypothesis classes to avoid paying for
the size of our state space or like
paying for the curse of dimensionality
um and in general
what
choice of model or hypothesis class
works well this will be something that's
like domain specific it could be neural
nets it could be forests it really
depends
but something i found in my own research
is that if we think about what
capabilities and understanding we have
for dealing with these sorts of flexible
models or hypotheses in
supervised learning
and then ask what happens when we try to
get similar capabilities for
reinforcement learning this leads to a
lot of really interesting research
questions okay
so
i'll just mention a couple of these
quickly so
the first one is algorithm design
so like how can we get general purpose
algorithms that work with any sort of
like class of models or hypotheses
um in supervised learning we saw this
principle erm just taking the model that
fits your data best and this can be
applied universally to any type of
hypothesis class but
for rl and like more broadly decision
making algorithm design at least on the
theoretical front has mostly proceeded
on a kind of case-by-case basis where
we're designing new algorithms for all
the different mod like every time we get
a new model we might want to experiment
with
and so given all the different types of
hypothesis classes there are
really what we'd like is algorithms that
can take this hypothesis class as an
input and start making accurate
decisions out of the box
um
so the other major research question
i'll mention here is sample complexity
like understanding
how many samples are necessary and
sufficient to learn for your problem
like in supervised learning we saw these
complexity measures like vc dimension
these give rates of convergence and they
also give fundamental limits on how many
samples you need to learn at least in
the worst case um beyond the worst case
is still a very active area of research
but in decision making
you know understanding sample complexity
this is very much tied to algorithm
design and as such a lot of our
understanding on the theoretical side is
is very case by case
and so i think it's really interesting
here to understand how this classical
curve of like risk versus amount of data
how this changes as we vary as we add
interactivity to the picture and you
know vary how complex our interactive
learning problem is
um
okay that was a lot to say about
generalization so let's come back to the
big picture
um
we have these three key challenges
and the idea is somehow any full
solution to the rl problem somehow needs
to put all of these together
um we saw that we have
solutions to all of these individual
problems and in fact
a lot of these are essentially classical
but where things get tricky is when we
start to combine them
um and so what it'll turn out is like
for any pair of these challenges we
actually have solutions here as well
although these are somewhat more recent
so for example if we want generalization
and exploration but only for a short
horizon this gives contextual bandits
um
but when you try to solve all three of
these challenges simultaneously this is
where we really get to like the frontier
for rl theory
um so with that in mind
the remainder for the roadmap or the the
roadmap for the remainder of the
tutorial is going to be
the first we're going to look at well
how do you solve all these challenges um
in pairs and what are the solutions
and then building on this
in the second part of the tutorial
i'll try to give the lay of the land
for when we want to solve all three
simultaneously
okay so
let's start going through
these sort of intermediate level
challenges
um and the first of these that we're
going to look at is
how do we combine exploration and credit
assignment
when we don't worry about
generalizing across states
um
so this is going to correspond to a
problem setting
that we call tabular reinforcement
learning and what this means is
reinforcement learning with a long
horizon like
big age
so i still care about credit assignment
but we have a small
finite state and action space
and the idea here is
because we're assuming the number of
states and actions is small we'll be
able to explicitly learn what to do in
every state directly we won't have to
worry about generalizing between states
but even though we care don't care about
generalization here
this is still a non-trivial problem in
the sense that if we think about these
environments like mazes or combination
locks where there's you know maybe a
single path that gets you towards the
goal
just exploring actions uniformly will
take an exponential number of tries
until we sample the right path and to
beat this we have to be deliberate in
how we explore
so
i'm going to describe a i think pretty
elegant solution to this problem which
is called the ucbvi algorithm and this
stands for upper confidence bound value
iteration so as the name suggests
this is just combining two techniques
we've already seen
optimism and dynamic programming
and i'll just describe what this
algorithm does in a given episode
so
uh there's a bunch of quantities we kind
of need to compute before i tell you the
core of the algorithm
um the first thing we're going to do is
compute
uh counts so
nt of x a x prime here is asking how
many times in the data i've seen so far
did i get to say x take action a and
then c state x prime
and then analogously n t of x a is just
how many times did i visit state x and
take action a
um so once we have these counts
we're going to use them to estimate the
transition probabilities
um and we're also going to take the
sample mean for each state action pair
so this will be called f hat t um f star
of x a here is denoted the true mean
reward for a given state in action
okay and the last thing we're going to
do here is similar to the bandit we'll
define a bonus but now for each state in
action so the bonus for action xa is
proportional to root 1 over the
visitation count for x and a
so
now that we have these quantities
defined i can tell you the main idea
behind the algorithm and this is very
simple
so we're just going to do value
iteration or dynamic programming
with our estimated rewards and
transitions
uh but the only catch is we're gonna add
these bonuses to the rewards and the
idea is this will encourage us to visit
new states and actions
so if we just walk through in a little
bit more detail what this value
iteration looks like
um we're going to have these functions q
bar and v bar which will denote our
optimistic estimates for the true q
functions and value functions
um
so we're starting just like in regular
dynamic programming with
v bar h plus one equal to zero
and at each step we're setting q bar h
of x a to be
the mean reward for the state in action
plus the bonus for the state in action
plus the expected value of v bar h plus
one but under our estimated transition
probabilities okay so we keep doing that
and once we have these optimistic q
functions we're gonna just play the
policy that uh you know optimizes the q
function
so
what you can show for this approach is
we have regret that scales linearly in
the horizon and then
with the square root of number of states
times the number of actions times the
number of episodes
um so this is actually mini max optimal
but the conceptual takeaway i want to
focus on is
we're polynomial in all the parameters
like number of right like time horizon
number of actions number of states and
this is reflecting the fact that we're
systematically exploring the unknown mdp
so naive exploration here
would have say
exponential
in the horizon in the sample complexity
you get
um i'll briefly mention
this follows a pretty long line of
research so you know the first few works
here we're mainly focused with well how
do we get sample complexity uh this
polynomial at all and this has gradually
been brought down to the rate i'm
showing here which is like the mini max
rate
um
with all these approaches though i'll
just mention
um these are what people typically refer
to as like model based and this is was
this referring to the fact that they're
explicitly estimating the transition
probabilities
um you can also look at what are called
model free methods which just try to
directly estimate the q functions
without estimating probabilities and you
can actually get similar regret bans
here but with all of these approaches
you're still memorizing like at least
one number for all the states so that
you're not you're not generalizing
across states
okay let's briefly go into how how you
prove this regret bound for ucbvi
um and the first step in the proof
just like for bandits will be to show
that our q functions q bar are
optimistic in the sense that they upper
bound q star everywhere
um so let's look at
the difference between
q star and q bar at step h which we want
to bound by zero
um and we're going to look at the we're
going to use the bellman optimality
condition to relate this difference to
the difference in the next step q
functions
so the idea is because q star satisfies
the bellman equation
we can write
this difference in terms of
the statistical error between our
rewards and transitions so
let's remember f star here is the mean
reward function so error of x a is just
f star minus f hat plus p minus p hat
um
so so we have this error term we're
subtracting off the bonus because the
bonus was added to q bar
and then we have the expected difference
between v star and v bar at the next
step
under the true model
and so the idea here is
if we use uh like concentration just
like we did for bandits
we can show that the bonus will dominate
the error term so we can write this off
as zero
and that's just going to leave us with
the difference between v star and v bar
at the next step
but the idea is like by the inductive
hypothesis uh we're actually done
because we're assuming that q bar is
optimistic for the next step so this is
also at most zero
okay and then once we have optimism
there are just a couple more steps um
the first one i won't go into detail
about here but the point will be that uh
using similar reasoning to the bandit
case
uh we can use optimism to show that our
sub-optimality in a given episode is
bounded by
uh you know the the sum of the bonuses
in this episode
okay and then if we look at regret we're
just gonna get the sum of bonuses
over all the episodes
and some and you know if you remember
how the bonuses are defined this is just
going to be
the like sum over t some over h
root one over the like count for the
state in action i visited
and because we have finite state actions
again
you know the the count for each state in
action can only shrink so much so again
using like a pigeon hole type are you in
you can show that this scales is like
root number of states number of actions
times t and that's it
um obviously
if you want if you really care about the
dependence on h here
you need to be a little more careful but
uh that's sort of a second order issue
okay uh let's move on
so that was all i wanted to say about
tabular rl
and the point for tabular rl was we're
solving exploration in the mdp setting
with a long horizon but the catch was we
had this finite state space so we can
afford to learn the dynamics or the
value function just by memorization in
every state
um
what we're going to do now is come back
to the contextual bandit problem
and the point of the contextual bandit
problem will be to incorporate
generalization
so this is a setting if you remember
from the intro where
it's rl with horizon one so there's no
credit assignment but now we do need to
worry about generalizing over context
which are what we call the states in
this setting so contacts are just states
and we have horizon one
and to make this idea kind of concrete
let's think about if we're trying to
recommend medical treatments to patients
um the context here could represent
information about a specific patient
we're trying to treat
and a particular patient will have you
know their own profile of rewards for
each treatment just like in the
multi-armed bandit but unlike in the
regular multi-armed bandit we're gonna
move from one patient to another or one
context to another
and a new patient might have
a profile of rewards that looks quite
different from the last patient and
others might be somewhere in between
so in general we can take the mean
reward for each action or treatment
and we can plot how this varies as we go
from
patient to patient or context to context
and this is going to give us a full
reward landscape where we have
uh potentially high dimensional
covariance or context as one axis and
actions is the other axis
and i find this landscape view
really useful to illustrate why this
setting captures both exploration and
generalization
so on one hand we have to explore
because we're only getting limited
feedback like if we see this user right
here and we recommend a particular
treatment we only see the feedback at a
particular point on the landscape where
these uh where the axes meet so we don't
see the reward function anywhere else so
we still need to be deliberate about how
we're gathering data
because if we otherwise if we just say
like run supervised learning on data we
gather it might have bias or it might be
misleading for places we haven't covered
but on the other hand
we still need to worry about
generalization because this this context
space is high dimensional and complex
like we may never see the exact same
context twice
so we
we will not have enough samples to get
away with just
memorizing what to do for each user um
instead somehow we need to propagate
information across this landscape so
that we can generalize and be
intelligent about how to explore and
exploit even for unseen contexts
so i'm going to describe a couple of
approaches to solving this challenge of
generalization and exploration
um and for both of these approaches
we'll take a modeling perspective
and assume that we have access to a
candidate class of reward functions
that's flexible enough to contain like
the true unknown mean reward function
so we're going to assume that we have a
hypothesis class script f
that contains this function f star of x
a which is just denoting like the
average kind of reward landscape here
like the landscape of our average awards
for each context in action
and you know we're calling script f here
a model class or a hypothesis class
because
just like in supervised learning this is
a model that's capturing our prior
knowledge about like the domain at hand
about like what we think that might the
landscape might look like
i'll just briefly mention this
assumption that we have a hypothesis
class that contains like somehow the
true reward function
this is often called realizability and
we're going to use this later in the
talk
okay
so one way you can try to solve this
setting
is
to use optimism as we've been doing so
far and you know directly maybe
generalize the multi-armed banded
approach we saw in the first part of the
talk
so we could try to construct something
like a ucb function
that upper bounds the true reward for
all contexts and actions and then you
know once i have a context i can just
take the action that has the highest ucv
here
so for example if you have a linear
model
where
f star is linear in some fixed context
action feature map in d dimensions
there's an algorithm called lin ucb um
that does exactly this right it just
estimates a linear model
builds an upward confidence bound pulls
the action that maximizes this and you
can show that the regret of this method
it scales with the dimension of the
feature map and not the number of
contexts or actions so
you are generalizing here but
fundamentally
uh the reason why this works is because
linear models let you extrapolate like
once you've explored a full basis worth
of directions you have a good estimate
for the rewards in any new direction you
might want to consider
um but unfortunately this approach
doesn't work in general so if you have
an arbitrary hypothesis class the issue
uh you know what should be familiar
coming from statistics is there's no
hope of constructing upper confidence
bounds that are valid for every state
or context
but at the same time shrink fast enough
to get non-trivial regret and that's
actually true even for something as
simple as like a single relu neuron
so
instead like another way that we can
attack this problem or another approach
you can take
is since we already have these different
models and algorithms that can do
generalization and supervised learning
um what if we could somehow reduce
contextual bandits to supervised
learning so that we can directly take
advantage of these results
and we actually have a recent method
that does exactly this um this is an
algorithm which we call square cb
and i'll try to just describe it on one
slide
so we're operating in this contextual
bandit setting uh t is the number of
episodes and i'm dropping like the h
subscript here because horizon is just
one
so the way this algorithm works is at
each round little t
we will get our context x t
and then we'll proceed as follows so
first we will use a supervised learning
algorithm to estimate the rewards based
on all the data we've gathered so far
and just think of this as like an off
the shelf algorithm for supervised
learning this could be like least
squares it could be sgd
on a neural net the reason we call this
square cv though is because we usually
use like least squares with the model of
choice
but once you have this estimator
we'll call this f hat t
um we're gonna use this to assign a
probability of being played
to each action
and then we'll just sample the action
from this distribution and update our
learning algorithm with the data we
observe
um and so the main thing i still need to
specify here is how do we assign this
probability to the actions
um and this we do using a technique
called inverse gap weighting and so the
way this works is
we'll first compute the greedy action
which we'll call b that has the highest
estimated reward
and for all the actions besides b we
assign them a probability with this uh
with this expression and i'll walk
through this step by step
so if we're looking at an action a
we're going to assign it a probability
that's inversely proportional to the gap
between its estimated reward
and the estimated reward of the greedy
action so this is like a reward gap so
we call it inverse gap weighting
and then we're going to scale this gap
by a learning rate parameter which we
call gamma
and then we'll add the number of actions
here for normalization
and finally we just give the greedy
action whatever mass is left over after
we do this for all the other actions
that's how we get the action
distribution again we just sample from
it
and update the the learning algorithm
with the
data we get
okay
so what it turns out is square cb
actually yields
uh sort of an optimal
and in a certain sense universal
reduction from contextual bandits to the
supervised learning problem so
if you form these estimates using a type
of supervised learning called online
regression you can show that for any
function class as long as you solve
supervised learning or estimation
optimally the square cd method solves
the contextual mandate problem optimally
i'll give a flavor of the result
so
we're going to let s
sq of t here sq is for square this will
just denote the
total squared error between
the estimators that our supervised
learning algorithm produces
and the true rewards for all the
contexts and actions we see
and so what you can show is that as long
as you choose the learning rate
correctly square cv will guarantee that
your regret is bounded by you know the
number of actions times t
times this estimation error so if you
have low estimation earlier you have low
regret in particular whenever you can
get sub-linear estimation error you can
get sub-linear regret
um this root a-t dependence
is optimal in a certain sense but it
it's easier to just walk through a
couple of examples so like for finite
classes you can show that the estimation
error
uh can be bounded by log cardinality of
the function class and this gives you
like root a t
times log cardinality regret for
contextual bandits which is optimal you
can do similar calculations for linear
models but the point is
as long as you're choosing the right
algorithm for supervised learning your
regret is going to scale just with like
the intrinsic complexity of your
hypothesis class and there's no
dependence on the size of the contact
space because we're generalizing across
contexts
and so like conceptually
the reason why this is nice is because
it's really giving like a unified
approach to designing algorithms and
understanding sample complexity in this
setting
i'll just give a couple remarks before i
move on
um so first of all why does this method
work at all
this is different from the other
approaches we've seen and it can't
really be interpreted as like optimistic
um and instead what you can show is that
this inverse gap weighting strategy
this solves a min max optimization
problem that links your contextual
bandit error to your estimation error on
a sort of like per round or per episode
basis
and i can go into more detail offline
but this is really just saying in a
direct sense find me a distribution over
actions such that regardless of what the
true reward function ends up being my
instantaneous banded error is controlled
by my instantaneous estimation error
um and the interesting feature is like
why this works is
this estimation or this this min max
problem it's completely agnostic to the
structure of the the hypothesis class
you're working with and i'll say more
about this later but this principle is
actually useful beyond just contextual
bandits
i'll just mention briefly on a
historical note you know contextual
minutes have seen a lot of development
up to this point
um but these results like square cd
where we can really like statistically
reduce the problem to
like classical supervised learning these
are actually pretty recent and we're now
just seeing these extend beyond
contextual bandits so like full rl um as
well as into production systems
um
yeah cause there's no distribution over
context here
um i mean you can assume one but you
don't need to
okay cool so we're coming to the last
part of
or the last you know component of part
one of this tutorial
and so the point is
we've seen how to solve exploration with
a long horizon with no generalization
we've seen exploration and
generalization without worrying about
horizon
now we're going to look at
how do we do
generalization
and credit is and
credit assignment so long horizon
when we don't need to worry about
exploration
and
the approach we're going to look at here
which is
well it's broadly from a family of
methods which are called direct policy
search
so as the name suggests
this is going to mean we're going to
kind of try to like just directly
optimize over policies that are good for
our reinforcement learning problem
rather than say
uh searching for q functions
and here's the motivation so
when i talked about generalization and
supervised learning earlier we're taking
a kind of classical perspective where
we're assuming we have some minimizer
for the training loss we're proving some
bound on the distance between train and
test error
um
a kind of more modern perspective
maybe a little more in the vein of like
deep learning is just to say we have
some big over parameterized model and
we're just going to treat this as like a
big stochastic optimization problem
and you can also apply this perspective
to rl
so
we're going to work with policies that
are parameterized by some vector in r to
the d
so pi theta will be the policy
corresponding to parameter theta
and our goal will just be to find
the parameter
that maximizes
uh the the reward of pi theta which
i'm going to try to show you can think
of as like a continuous stochastic
optimization problem that you can
optimize using first order methods like
gradient descent
in order for this to work the first kind
of basic technique we're going to use
is to work with what are called
stochastic policies
and this just means policies that map
uh states to distributions over actions
rather than like discrete actions
the reason why we're going to use
stochastic policies is that they'll give
us a way to make sure that we have a
continuous optimization problem
and typically the way we'll do this i'm
just going to give one example is
we'll set the probability that uh our
policy pi theta selects an action a
to be proportional to like uh soft max
of some continuous function
of our parameter and the com the states
in actions so like f theta here it could
be a linear function parameterized by
theta or it could be like a deep neural
net parameterized by theta but the point
is
as long as uh f theta here is continuous
when we do some continuous map like soft
max
this cos j pi theta will be continuous
as well and we can throw gradient based
methods at it
okay so let's look at how we do this
there is a question on the chat if you
want to interest really
there's a distribution of our contacts
oh i i actually answered that already
but i mean that's from the previous part
the contextual mandatory
yeah
cool
um
yeah so okay so we have this continuous
objective
j pi theta how can we optimize this you
know the first tool you might try here
is just gradient descent so like at each
episode
uh you know compute the gradient of this
objective with respect to
theta at my current iterate and you know
add this to the current parameter scaled
by some learning rate
um and the only question here is how do
i compute this gradient so like j of pi
is an expectation under this kind of
complex process where we're running our
policy and seeing how
the system like the mdp evolves and
we're only seeing trajectories like we
don't just have some oracle that gives
us the gradient
but
there's a really useful trick that we
can use to estimate the gradient from
trajectories and this is called the
policy gradient theorem
so what this says is
uh
we can write the gradient of this
objective with respect to theta
as an expectation under a process where
we're running our own policy so pi theta
and this is the expectation of kind of
two terms so
it's the sum of the rewards for our
trajectory
times the sum of gradients of the log
probabilities that our policy is
assigning to the actions and states that
are encountered
and the point here is
both the quantities in this expectation
are things that we can calculate based
only on the trajectory we observe when
we run our policy
and so we can get an unbiased estimator
just by
you know running for a bunch of episodes
and approximating this expectation from
samples
and i won't go into detail about how you
prove this but the basic idea is just
you use what's called the log derivative
trick so this says if i have some
function g of theta i can write the
gradient
as the value times the gradient of the
log
um
like why do you care about doing this
well the point is just to keep the value
of pi theta around so that you can write
this quantity as an expectation which
facilitates estimating from samples like
i said
all right um and that's the basic scheme
you know estimate this gradient from
samples do a gradient descent update as
you can imagine there are many variants
based on changing either how do we do
the gradient update how do we estimate
the gradients um but the point i'll
emphasize here is like the policy
gradient theorem
is what's taking care of credit
assignment right it's telling me when i
see a particular trajectory and the
rewards for it
how could i have changed my policy to
improve the outcome
um and i'll just
give a quick sense for what the theory
results look like here
um
i'll start by just saying a
representative guarantee for the tabular
setting
even though our goal was to understand
generalization here this is the simplest
setting to start with because
i can pick a parameterization that lets
me represent any policy
but this will still rep uh like
illustrate some of the key issues
so
i'm going to pick a parameterization
where i have a number for each state
action pair that represents the
probability so theta x a is just the
probability i select action a and say x
and what you can do with this approach
is show that
the
sub optimality
for any policy pi theta is going to be
bounded by
the norm of the gradient
at this policy or at this parameter
times
a mismatch parameter
that quantifies
uh sort of
how far the policy
the state distribution induced by the
policy we're looking at is from the
state distribution of the optional
policy
um and so the point is
you can easily drive the norm of the
gradient here to zero
with any first order method
and so the the the point to focus on is
like the mismatch parameter um and you
can think of this as controlling
how much x you get to explore for free
so this is saying for a given policy
what is the ratio of the probability
that we visit a state action pair under
this policy versus the probability that
we visit it under the optimal policy
and so you can think of this as
capturing like how easy is your mdp to
explore so like if you passively visit
any state regardless of what you do
this parameter is going to be small
but if you have a domain uh where you
need to systematically explore
it can be large
but the important thing to understand is
like
this bound is actually tight
yeah so there's one question for you
just to understand the the ratio depends
in the
initial condition
because
as it is i cannot see where the the
policy
takes place because it's just the
transition
map of the
oh sorry yeah so just a note on notation
so
p superscript pi is supposed to denote
the probability that
you know x h is x and a h is a
when i run policy pi
but why uh
i i thought that this is pretty fine
from the mdp uh that i am running not
from
where is the policy that uh plays some
road
well what state you like what state i so
so if h is one this doesn't depend on
the policy but the point is like you
know what the probability that i end up
in a given state at time h is going to
depend on all of the actions i've
selected leading up to
okay and time
is the reason that they say that that i
assume that it is uh over all the in
probably initial uh
initial stage that you have take
yeah that's that's supposed to be like
incorporated into this expression okay
yeah
cool
um
let's see where was i yeah so
the point i just wanted to say is like
the fact that like naive policy gradient
methods depend on this sort of parameter
like this is real so you can construct
even just tabular mdps where
the ucb vi method i showed earlier will
get sample complexity that's polynomial
in all of the like problem parameters
but this mismatch can be you know
arbitrarily large really
um but the point like the reason we like
this though is that like if we have tons
and tons of data this mismatch can
potentially be okay
and
the and the nice thing is like it's easy
to scale these methods to
you know
bigger problems like continuous problems
and incorporate function approximation
and i won't go into much detail on this
but the point is that like when you move
to general function approximations the
the the the style of the result you can
get would say that like you know
uh my sub optimality is going to be
controlled by
some parameter i'm calling epsilon opt
which reflects like how well you can do
stochastic optimization which is going
to be related to like you know
how flexible your hypothesis class is
and how well you can generalize
again this will be scaled by a mismatch
parameter
but on top of this you'll also pay for
some bias that reflects like you know is
your representation for these policies
powerful enough to actually
you know capture the the policies that
it needs to for the underlying mdp
okay
um
so just briefly touch on the history
here so this idea of direct policy
search like optimizing over policies
this is pretty classical but you know
these these methods have really had a
surge in popularity in the last decade
or so in the context of like deep rl
where we imagine that we're using like
deep neural nets to represent these
policies and this is the approach
behind a lot of the empirical successes
we've seen for say like continuous
control problems
um i'll just say on the theory side the
idea of proofing like non-asymptotic
guarantees here
has really only started picking up steam
in the last couple of years and i think
there's a lot of really interesting
questions here in terms of understanding
like when do these methods actually work
what is really like the geometry of
these problems and how can you improve
these methods by combining them with
exploration
um okay
so that's actually going to bring us to
the end of part one of the tutorial
um i'm gonna stop now but when we get
back we'll look at how can we solve you
know all three of these challenges
simultaneously
like exploration
generalization
credit assignment
and we'll try to understand what is
really like the landscape of what we
currently
know about rl theory okay so i'll stop
there and i can take further questions
one question had is uh i'm not sure you
went into like more model based
approaches like there was no like
modeling of the actual reward function
um like assumptions about the real world
like that maybe you can you can make
that will help you
yeah the only um
the only
sort of setting i really went into so
far where we did that was like the
contextual bandits where i'm modeling
the reward functions so that's
that's all of everything we'll see in
the second part of the tutorial is going
to focus on exactly that problem though
like
and that's really kind of coming back to
this point about like
generalization
yeah because like why do you do modeling
you do modeling because you care about
generalizing
thanks thank you
[Applause]
so we're gonna have a half hour break
and then there's the next session is
gonna go out until 12 10.
good
thanks